Transcriber: gaith Takrity
المدقّق: Zain Al Amir Bourak
سنة 2010 مثل أي طفل يمارس
حياته بشكل طبيعي .
بدأت أشعر في وجع بقدمي.
هذا شيء ادخلني بدوامة لا أعلم أسبابها.
بعد زيادة عدد من الأطباء ، تم تشخيصي
بالإصابة بسرطان العضلة .
وبدأت فعلا بعلاج بمركز الحسين
للسرطان لمدة سنة ونصف.
بعد أخذ العلاج لمدة سنة ونصف،
قرر الأطباء بأنه ليس هناك استجابة
للعلاج ، و أن السرطان ينتشر أكثر .
كان الحل الوحيد هو أن يعملوا بتر
لقدمي لأحافظ على حياتي.
بصراحة في البداية كان في صدمة كبيرة
أنه سوف أخسر قدمي.
وبعد أخذ العلاج لمدة سنة ونص
والآثار الجانبية للعلاج .
و الآثار الجانبية للعلاج
الكيميائي كانت جدا صعبة.
بدأت أفكر كيف سيكون شكل الحياة الجديدة ؟
هل سيتقبلني المجتمع؟
هل سأستطيع الزواج ؟
هل سيكون لي بصمة على هذه الأرض أم لا ؟
من الأفكار التي خطرت لي
كيف سأواجه هذه الحياة
والتحديات الموجودة فيها؟
وفعلا . بعد كل هذه الأسئلة التي خطرت لي .
لم يكن هناك سوى حل وحيد و هو تقبل الحقيقة
وتقبل الأمر الواقع الآن الذي أواجهه .
تعرفوا لم يكن هناك مهرب من بتر قدمي.
للمحافظة على حياتي .
هذا الشيء أعطاني قوة وعزيمة وإرادة أكثر
لأستمر في الحياة وأستطيع أن أساعد المجتمع
وأقدر أكون رمز .
حتى الناس تكون عم تشوف دعم
القضايا الإنسانية من خلال الجبال .
طبيعتي أحب الرياضة ، لكن تعرفوا كنت أتمنى
أن أكون برياضة مميزة برياضة خطيرة
حتى أثبت لنفسي وللآخرين أن الإنسان
قادر على تحقيق المستحيل.
فعلا بدأت بتسلق الجبال .بالبداية
لم أكن أعرف أي شيء عن تسلق الجبال.
بدأت ابحث و أتعلم كيف ممكن اتسلق الجبال
بقدم واحدة وطبعا هذا يحتاج مجهود عالي
خصوصا بأن التسلق يحتاج
قدمين وأنا بقدم واحده.
وفعلا بدأت أتعمق أكثر بالتسلق
وأحببت تلك الرياضة
لأنه من خلالها اكتشفت نفسي .
قمت برحلتي الأولى لجبال عجلون وفعلا
لم تكن بتجربة سهلة، كانت صعبة
لأن التسلق كما تحدثت سابقاً يحتاج لقدمين.
يحتاج لجسم قوي جدا .
فكان الحل الوحيد هو تدريب أكثر وأكثر
حتى انغمس بهذه الرياضة.
وفعلا بعد التسلق في عجلون
فكرت لماذا لا ابدأ أتسلق
قمم أكبر من هذه، وبدأت أفكر
بقمم محلية وقمم عالمية، فبدأت بتسلق
أعلى قمة بالأردن هي جبال أم الدامي
وبعدها.. هنا الشغف زاد وحبي للتسلق زاد.
لأنه من خلاله استطعت أن أعبر عن نفسي وعن
الشيء الذي اشعر به ومايشعر به الناس أيضاً
و أن أوصل أيضا هذه الرسالة
إلى العالم كله من خلال التسلق .
بعدها فكرت لماذا لا أبدأ بتسلق قمم عالمية
تعلموا هناك سبع قمم بالعالم
وبكل قارة هناك أعلى قمة.
وفعلا عملت رحلتي الأولى لجبل كليمنجارو .
هذه الرحلة لم تكن سهلة أبدا .
بدأت أفكر كيف ممكن أوصل رسالتي ورسالة
القضايا الإنسانية للمجتمع؟
حتى يصل صوتي من خلال القمم .
وفعلا بعدها قمت برحلتي الأولى بعمل حملة
عام 2018 لدعم تعليم الأطفال ولاجئين فلسطين
وقمت بتسلق مخيم قاعدة جبل إيفرست
حتى أوصل رسالتها للأطفال من خلال القمة .
فعلا الحمد لله استطعت أن أجمع ما يقارب 150
ألف دولار حتى يستمر الأطفال بالتعليم.
تعرفون من المواقف التي لا أنساها خلال
تسلقي مخيم قاعدة جبل إيفرست
عندما فتحت موبايلي و رأيت
طفلا يرسل لي جراح .
نحن ننتظرك لتساعدنا وتساعد تعليمنا .
بصراحة هذه الجملة كانت كفيلة بدفعي الى
القمة بشكل يعني خرافي
جعلتني لا أنظر إلى الصعوبات و التحديات
التي نواجهها خلال التسلق .
وفعلا اندفعت إلى القمة بكل حب وبكل
طاقة حتى أدعم هؤلاء الطلاب .
تعرفون بطبيعتي أحب المساعدة .
أحببت أن أجمع بين تسلقي
ودعم القضايا الإنسانية
وأتخيل أن هذا أعطى قيمة أكثر لتسلقي .
أشعر بإحباط وقلق بعض الأحيان من الأشياء
التي سأواجهها أثناء التسلق
لكن دائما بحكي إن الهدف أقوى وأسمى
الموضوع الذي سأركز عليه
اليوم هو دعم المجتمع وتطوره
وأهميتهم في حياة الشخص بحيث أنه يصقل
من شخصيتك وتجعلك تتعامل مع المدراء
تتعامل بالتنظيم والاستفادة من البرامج التي
تقوم على دمج الشباب في سوق العمل.
اتخيل التطوع خلال فترة الدراسة مهم
جدا لصقل وتقوية المهارات عندنا
فعندما ندخل لسوق العمل
نكون منغمسين بكل أريحية .
لا تشعر أن هناك شئ جديد توجهت اليه.
الدرس الذي أريد أن أنادي به اليوم
إن الإنسان قادر على تحقيق المستحيل، لكن
يحتاج لثلاثة أشياء العمل والاجتهاد
والإيمان بالنفس .
وفي الوقت نفسه إن التطوع
خلال الدراسة مهم جدا
لصقل وتقوية المهارات
العملية والعلمية والاجتماعية .
وهذا شيء له أثر كبير علينا بالمجتمع كون
نحن جزء لا يتجزأ من هذا المجتمع .
أحب أن أحكي لكم
حاولوا تغلبوا على المشاكل التي تواجهوها
بكل أمل و بكل حب و بكل دافعية
لحد تثبت أنك موجود على هذه الأرض
ولك بصمة وتساعد الآخرين .
بعد تسلق قمم كثيرة قمم حقيقية
وجسدية ونفسية واجتماعية
بتخيل لقيت المعنى لحياتي هو تسلق الجبال
و دعم القضايا الإنسانية من خلال التسلق
هذه قصتي, فما قصتكم ؟